[Musique]
la ville
ces immeubles ces voitures sa pollution
et son béton sur les routes sous nos
pieds il est partout une soif de béton
qui date des années 70 grignotant
toujours un peu plus les espaces verts
le réchauffement climatique nous oblige
pourtant à faire marche arrière
la solution serait-elle de remettre la
nature au cœur de la ville les citoyens
en sont convaincus du bitume aux arbres
fruitiers au cœur du vieux tour ce sont
les habitants qui ont demandé à la
municipalité de créer ce petit écrin de
verdure
[Musique]
d'avant il faut biner
[Rires]
dans ce verger urbain de 300 mètres
carrés les riverains prennent soin de
pommiers amandiers framboisiers ou
encore de plantes aromatiques les
habitants et commerçants parent tout son
arbre comme Alain qui veille sur son
Poirier
énormément les plantations surtout les
jeunes parce que les arbres beaucoup
plus implantés comme celui qui est
derrière là ils n'ont pas besoin d'être
arrosés il y a de l'eau dans le sol
quand même donc réguler tous les jours
on venait voir si tous les arbres
avaient besoin d'être arrosés ou pas
c'est participer un peu à la vie du
quartier c'est surtout ça et puis c'est
vrai que je trouve que ça manque
vraiment la végétation en ville surtout
que paradoxalement on a
on dit il faut végétaliser et puis on
met de la pierre et du béton partout
quoi enfin c'est paradoxal on dit un
truc on fait le contraire
même en plein hiver il y a toujours
quelque chose à faire
c'est une amie
[Musique]
le collectif s'est réuni pour protéger
les arbres du froid avec du paillage ça
marche pas mal de chacun essayer de
transmettre ses connaissances ou n'en
n'ayant pas d'acquérir des connaissances
bah là il y a des gens qui disent que
avant ils sortaient le goudron
maintenant ils saute la nature donc ça
plaît plutôt bien il y a pas mal de
passages c'est une place qui commence à
être bien bien repéré maintenant au
niveau du quartier
il y a urgence à vegetaliser depuis 1950
le thermomètre dans nos centres-villes
ne cesse de grimper en Centre-Val de
Loire la température a déjà augmenté de
deux degrés la faute à des sols
imperméables qui emmagasinent la chaleur
pour éviter que nos villes ne deviennent
des fours il faut donc remettre de la
nature dans l'urbain
au nord de Tours le conseil de quartier
a sauvé une friche du béton pour y
implanter une mini forêt un millier
d'arbres a été planté sur cet espace
d'un hectare
ce terrain était un terrain vague qui
devait devenir soit un parking soit un
immeuble et en fait l'atelier
environnement du Conseil du quartier de
Tours Saint-Symphorien à initier les dés
de faire une mini forêt
ce sont de jeunes arbres qui ont été
plantés
à l'heure qu'il est difficile de se
projeter il faudra attendre 5 ans pour
obtenir un résultat
l'intérêt de planter des petits arbres
c'est que en fait ils prennent racine
ils prennent mieux racine et en fait on
estime que en plantant des petits arbres
il pousseront beaucoup mieux beaucoup et
aussi vite que des arbres qui sont un
beaucoup plus grand ça mène de la
fraîcheur ça apaise aussi les gens ça
diminue le bruit en ville alors
notamment avec la circulation au niveau
du rond-point ce qui est bien aussi
c'est que les gens se rendre compte du
temps la temporalité des arbres selon un
récent rapport du GIEC Groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat impliquer les citoyens et
essentiels pour une transformation
écologique réussie
la ville de Tours qui a cofinancé ce
projet la bien compris
son pédagogie les gens ils accrochent
pas on le sait ça fait 40 ans que les
choses se disent que les scientifiques
nous disent il y a un problème ça va
être catastrophe et finalement quand on
regarde on a vachement peu changé nos
habitudes même pire en fait nous nous
missions carbone continuent à augmenter
on a toujours plus de voitures on
imperméabilise je sais plus combien de
d'hectares par an en France donc c'est
clair que si on veut changer le monde on
changera pas son légende au monde
dans l'équipe municipale aux côtés des
adjoints aux finances et à la culture
c'est élu a une nouvelle casquette
déléguée à la biodiversité et à la
nature en ville
il faut que on dépasse le cadre
utilitaire de la nature d'être dans un
parc oui c'est utilitaire pour aller
vers du patrimoine et c'est ainsi que
nous nous appelons patrimoine végétal et
biodiversité et le patrimoine végétal
c'est ce qu'on veut conserver c'est ce
qu'on veut protéger
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé fixe
la norme d'espaces verts à 12 mètres
carrés par habitant à moins de 300
mètres du lieu de vie les initiatives
citoyennes ne suffiront pas à atteindre
cet objectif
les collectivités doivent-elles aussi
s'emparer du sujet à Olivet cela
commence par les cours d'école car
parfois il faut déconstruire pour mieux
construire
nous sommes ici dans la cour historique
de l'école du centre-ville d'Olivet
l'école du Poutine et depuis très
longtemps les enfants jouent ici lorsque
nous avons fait le projet de
reconstruction de et de rénovation de
l'école nous sommes beaucoup concentrés
sur la cour on voulait conserver
l'alignement d'arbre qui pour certains
étaient là depuis plusieurs dizaines
d'années et on a voulu sortir de l'îlot
de chaleur qui était provoquée par le
goudron parce que là on a orienté plein
sud
pour remplacer le goudron la mairie a
trouvé une alternative
ce sol là il a deux vertus principales
la première c'est qu'il est clair donc
il ne conserve pas la chaleur il la
réfléchit et puis il est très perméable
l'eau
peut s'infiltrer avec ce revêtement
c'est 4 à 5 degrés de moins pour nos
chérubins par forte chaleur
dans la cour voisine c'est un sol
naturel qui a été privilégié
l'architecte dans ses premiers plans
goudronnait la cour et on lui a dit bah
non il y a pas de raison de la
goudronnée il y avait de la terre battue
est-ce qu'on peut continuer à travailler
avec un revêtement de sol naturel il a
été très surpris parce que c'était pas
les demandes qu'il avait l'habitude de
recevoir de la part des élus mais très
enthousiasmé parce qu'il était très
sensible aux questions de transition et
donc on est parti avec ce revêtement
gravillonnaire et les enfants se sont
tout à fait bien adaptés à ce revêtement
de sol
la ville d'Olivet s'est mise au défi de
transformer toutes ses cour d'école
cette au total dans cette maternelle des
travaux sont en cours des espaces vont
être créés pour faire classe dehors et
un potager ainsi que des arbres seront
implantés
[Musique]
rendre sa place à la nature c'est
parfois prendre des décisions
courageuses imaginez tout un quartier
détruit à Blois des habitations qui
disparaissent comme par magie ou presque
il a fallu 15 ans pour désurbaniser ce
quartier et lui rendre sa fonction
première celle de déversoir en cas de
débordement de la Loire une opération
unique en France
nous sommes ici à Blois dans le quartier
Vienne dans le quartier de la bouillie
c'est un quartier qui était totalement
urbanisé et il y avait des maisons plus
d'une centaine de maisons quelques
entreprises et c'est un quartier que
nous avons dû désurbaniser pour prévenir
les risques d'inondation
des crues centenal il n'y en a pas eu
depuis 150 ans alors forcément les
habitants ont oublié ce danger mais avec
des épisodes d'inondation de plus en
plus violents le dérèglement climatique
ne peut plus être ignoré la démolition
des bâtiments et devenue indispensable
ce quartier représentait un vrai risque
pour ses habitants évidemment mais un
vrai risque pour les 5000 habitants de
ce côté-ci de la route parce que les
habitations pouvaient se transformer en
projectile qui aurait percuté la digue
et qui aurait fait que tout le quartier
aurait été inondé
cet espace de 350 hectares va être
aménagé en parc naturel urbain avec des
lieux de promenade des activités de
pâturage et de maraîchage
il faut retrouver une relation avec la
nature il faut retrouver une relation
apaisée il faut lutter contre ce qu'on
appelle les îlots de chaleur urbain mais
il faut pas se focaliser sur tel ou tel
aspect il faut avoir une vision globale
et tout simplement se souvenir que nos
ancêtres quand ils construisait une
ville il tenait compte de la géographie
les cours d'eau les montagnes les zones
il faut tout simplement retrouver ce bon
sens paysan
justement et si nos campagnes avaient
elles aussi besoin de renouer avec la
nature la question n'est pas réservée
qu'aux grandes villes à Marseille dans
le Berry la municipalité a bien saisi
tout l'enjeu de préserver le bocage qui
entoure ce village de 300 habitants
ici comme partout l'arrachage des haies
est une pratique courante
[Musique]
pour encourager les agriculteurs à
entretenir c'est le bois de taille est
racheté par la mairie pour chauffer les
bâtiments communaux
la valorisation de cet espace naturel
revêt de nombreux avantages
[Musique]
le bocage est vraiment à nid de
biodiversité extraordinaire avec
beaucoup de beaucoup de fautes beaucoup
de fleurs et puis pour les agriculteurs
voilà le bocage c'est aussi la
sauvegarde du de l'élevage de l'élevage
traditionnel et donc pour la commune
c'est aussi sauvegarder une activité
économique même si les la conservation
des ça pour les agriculteurs et c'est
pour cela que nous nous sommes dirigés
vers ce chauffage parce que ça permet de
rémunérer les agriculteurs pour
l'entretien de la
au sein de l'école la commune a fait
installer en 2013 une chaufferie à bois
en plaquettes
le bois taillé par les agriculteurs et
transformé dans une coopérative
je bois c'est effectivement ça c'est du
ce qu'on appelle du bois des chiqueté de
vous des plaquettes de bois qui sont qui
sont amenés qui sont stockés dans la
dans un stylo et amené par les
agriculteurs par Ben céréalière
préserver la nature elle vous le rendra
bien cette chaudière chauffe l'école la
mairie la crèche la Poste la salle des
fêtes ainsi que 5 logements des chars
2013 a dès la première année en a
effondré notre facture de chauffage un
des deux tiers alors déjà vous pensez
maintenant on est vraiment on est
vraiment les rois du monde du coup de ce
du côté de l'énergie on a effectivement
une facture énergétique en fait pour
pour vous l'expliquer très clairement on
paye aujourd'hui pour plus de deux fois
plus de surface on paye moins que en
2012 pour le chauffage de l'école et de
la mairie avec du chiot
[Musique]
8 Français sur 10 trouvent qu'il n'y a
pas assez de végétal en centre-ville un
chiffre en forte progression depuis les
dernières élections locales de quoi
donner des idées à nos politiques pour
leur prochaine campagne
je crois que j'ai besoin d'un peu d'air
frais d'une balade en forêt j'ai plus
trop ce que je fais la vie une
[Musique]